[DIGITAL EFFECTS]
NANCY KANWISHER:
So to remind you,
we've been talking last
week about doing two things
at once-- asking all sort of
questions of what we might want
to know about face perception
in the brain-- there
are some questions.
But at the same
time, the agenda has
been to consider the
different methods
available in human cognitive
neuroscience and what kinds
of questions each
one can answer.
So last week, we talked
about a bunch of them,
and today, we're
going to wrap this
up talking about TMS
and animal studies.
But first, I just want to
remind you very briefly--
I won't go through in
excruciating detail--
we talked about
behavioral methods, which
are great for characterizing
internal representations,
as you saw with face
inversion effects and some
of the other
behavioral data, they
have major disadvantages, which
is that with behavior, you're
just measuring the output.
It's pretty sparse.
And from that, you have to infer
all the stuff that happened in
between the retina-- or whatever
your sensory modality is--
and the output.
All that internal
mental stuff you
have to infer just
from the output.
So it's amazing that
that works at all,
and you have to be
really smart to do it.
And lots of people have been
doing that for a long time,
but it's challenging.
So why not look inside?
And one of the best ways
to do that, of course,
is functional MRI.
It has the best
spatial resolution
available for normal subjects.
But as you guys all
seem to pick up on,
its temporal
resolution is lousy,
and its ability to tell you
whether the neural activity
you're looking at is
causally involved in behavior
is like nil.
Now, at least one of you--
I only read a few
of the assignments--
but at least one
of you was confused
about which causal role
we're talking about.
And this is actually
really important.
So let's take a moment
to talk about this.
Causality, the
idea of causality--
if x causes y, that means,
essentially, y wouldn't have
happened without x,
or y happened more
because x happened,
when x happens
than when x doesn't happen.
So that's pretty basic.
So that means if you want to
test the causal role of x on y,
you have to mess with x.
That's the key challenge.
OK, so with that in mind,
here's this whole causal chain.
A stimulus lands on a retina.
A bunch of neural
activity happens,
and some behavioral
output happens.
So there's a whole
causal chain there.
Now, let's consider what kind of
causality we're talking about.
There's one kind which is
that the stimulus causes
neural activity in the brain.
That's a kind of causality
that we can absolutely
test, even if we're measuring
that with functional MRI,
because we can mess
with the stimulus.
We can present different
stimuli and produce
different neural activity, OK?
So in that case, we can
look at the causal effect
of the stimulus on
the neural activity.
No problem.
That's standard.
That's what we do, pretty much,
in every experiment with ERPs,
or functional MRI, or so forth.
Is that clear?
OK, on the other
hand, if we want
to know this kind of causality
from some neural activity we
measure in the brain to
either a behavioral response,
or a subjective feeling reported
by a behavioral response,
or something like that,
that's the challenging part.
That's the kind of causality
that we can't infer
from ERPs or functional MRI.
Everyone got that?
Yeah, OK, it's sort of
obvious and not obvious.
OK, so let's talk
a little bit more
about that temporal resolution.
I know I kept saying
the temporal resolution
of functional MRI is lousy,
but I had run out of time
and skipped through the key
slide, So let me back up
and do that here.
This is the BOLD or MRI
response as a function of time.
This is an idealized
version of it,
but it looks kind of like that.
And sorry these things are tiny
here, but these are seconds--
5 seconds, 10 seconds.
So let me show you
what that means.
If you're recording
neural activity,
back here, in the first stage of
visual processing in the cortex
coming up from the
eyes-- which is where?
AUDIENCE: The occipital lobe.
NANCY KANWISHER: The
occipital lobe, yes.
What area?
AUDIENCE: Primary visual cortex.
NANCY KANWISHER: Primary
visual cortex, exactly.
OK, so suppose that
we stuck an electrode
in my primary visual
cortex, and we flashed up
a very brief visual display.
OK, here's a visual stimulus, on
for maybe a tenth of a second--
bright, flashing
thing V1 loves--
V1, also primary
visual cortex, right?
OK, the neural activity would
happen in less than 1/10
of a second-- super fast.
We know that from
work in animals
and even some work
in humans, OK?
So super fast
after the stimulus.
It just goes straight up
from the retina, the LGN V1--
boom, there it is.
So all the neural activity
happens right there,
and it ends right there.
But the MRI response is
five, six seconds later--
this big, sloppy, slow
thing as the blood slashes
into V1 many seconds after
the relevant neural activity.
So what's relevant here is
not just that it's delayed,
but it's big and sloppy.
And so both of those
things are the reasons
why functional MRI responses
aren't good for distinguishing
what happens on a fine temporal
scale of, say, events less
than a second.
All right, OK, in
contrast, as I mentioned,
when you glue
electrodes on the scalp,
or stick these fancy magnetic
sensors in the big hairdryer
device around your
head, there you
get beautiful
temporal resolution,
but it's like the
Heisenberg principle
of cognitive neuroscience.
You want time, you
don't get space.
OK, and similarly,
here, we can measure
the causal effect on scalp
response neural responses,
but not the causal role of those
neural responses on behavior.
Everyone clear with this?
OK.
OK, then I talked
about these rare cases
where we can record
directly from the surface
of the human brain with
electrical activity, where
we now get both space and
time at the same time.
And the key disadvantage
there, of course,
is that it's extremely invasive.
You have to take a big piece
of skull off to get in there.
And, of course, that
would only happen
in the case of people
who are already in pretty
serious medical circumstances.
OK, so now, when we have
this incredible opportunity
to record this amazing data
from the center of the brain,
does that enable us to make
this kind of causal inference
from neural activity
to behavior?
Yes?
What do you think, yes?
No?
Isabelle?
Is that Isabelle?
Yes.
Why are you shaking your head?
AUDIENCE: Because
it just tells us
which neurons are
responsible for [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: That's right.
It's cooler, it's
fancier, it's more
impressive than
functional MRI or ERPs,
but it's still the same deal.
We're just recording
responses, OK?
So we can do this
causality, from the stimulus
to those neural
responses, but it
doesn't tell us which
of those responses
are related to behavior yet.
I showed you other methods that
do, but this one alone doesn't.
Everybody got that?
All right, so then I talked
about studying patients
with focal brain damage.
And here, you really can
make a strong causal link
between a bit of brain
and a behavioral ability.
You lose that bit of brain,
you can no longer do that task.
That's a really direct
kind of causal role.
I talked about
double associations.
I gave it short shrift, but
it's actually really important.
You should know it.
A double dissociation is when
you have one patient who can do
A but not B-- say, recognize
objects but not faces--
and another patient who
can do B but not A--
say, recognize faces
but not objects.
And when you have in the
literature two cases like that,
now you're in a
really strong position
to infer that there's something
fundamentally different
about face recognition
and object recognition
in the brain.
OK, so that's really
important-- the senses
in which a double association
is more inferentially powerful
than a single association.
OK, "more important" means
I'm sure to test you on it.
No, it's also important, whether
I was going to test you on it
or not.
[LAUGHS]
OK, and so, of course,
in focal brain damage,
we can absolutely infer causal
role from a bit of brain
to a behavioral ability.
Lose that bit of brain,
lose the ability, yeah?
OK.
And the case that I showed
you with that amazing movie
of the guy getting stimulated
in his fusiform face area
and seeing percepts of faces on
top of whatever he looked at,
that's a quintessential
beautiful example
of the causal role of
neural activity there.
We're basically directly
manipulating neural activity.
We're injecting neural
activity there electrically
and looking at the behavioral
and cognitive result that
occurs--
The guy.
Sees a hallucinatory face.
OK, now, that is amazing
data, but as I mentioned,
they're very rare.
We have no control over it.
When we get those data, we
celebrate and are all excited,
but mostly, we don't
get those data.
Plus, those people have serious
problems with their brains.
That's why their brains
are being opened up.
So is there any way
to test a causal role
of a particular part of the
brain in a normal subject
who doesn't have their
skull open for neurosurgery
and who has not
had brain damage?
Well, there's one
way, and that's
called transcranial
magnetic stimulation, OK?
So in transcranial
magnetic stimulation,
you take a coil of
wire about yea big.
That's a tight-wrapped coil
of wire embedded in plastic,
connected to a
ginormous capacitor,
and you hold it
next to your head.
Of course, that's
what you would do
if you were a neuroscientist.
And you discharge and
make an enormous current
through that coil that's very,
very strong and very brief.
The whole thing lasts
less than one millisecond.
And you guys know from
8.02, another case
of the right-hand rule
coming to our service.
You have a hell of a
current going in a coil.
What's going to happen in
brain tissue underneath?
AUDIENCE: Increase the
magnetic [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: The electric
field will [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, exactly.
And so you'll get electric
fields perpendicular
to the coil sticking right
into the brain like that.
And what do you think
happens if you stick a big,
huge transient electric
field-- boom!--
into your head like that.
AUDIENCE: Isn't that a
magnetic field [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, you're right.
Right-hand rule
is magnetic field.
I was thinking I was
misremembering, right?
Electric current makes
magnetic field, right?
It was a long time
ago I took 8.02.
I did-- just a long time ago.
Anyway, for current
purposes, doesn't matter.
Either would do it.
Actually, there's
a variant of this
where it's an electric
field, but it's
debated how well that works.
OK, anyway, what
happens is you affect
neural activity in tissue right
underneath the skull, right?
OK, so if you want to
see a picture, a video
of that happening,
there's a video
of me getting zapped
with TMS on my website.
You can check it out.
It's kind of ludicrous.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: What's the
spatial resolution?
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh,
we're getting there.
We're getting there.
OK, here's an early
version of this.
To generate these very strong
and brief magnetic fields,
they had these stacks
of coils like this,
and they rotated them around.
It's a little crazy.
Here's a more recent version.
It looks like a
big torture device,
but it's actually no big deal.
The guy's just holding
his head on a chin rest
to hold his head
still, and there's
a person holding the coil
next to his head like that.
And so that enables us
to briefly and somewhat
selectively disrupt a
little patch of cortex
there by sticking in
this big random field.
Now, spatial resolution
is not amazing--
maybe 1, 2 centimeters,
something like that, OK?
It's better than you
might guess for such
an incredibly crude device--
like something people would
have done hundreds years ago,
and yet we still do it today.
You can also use a lovely method
where you scan the subject with
functional MRI first, find a
particular functional region
that you're interested in in
that person's brain-- remember,
these things can vary in
their exact location across
subjects--
and then find a way to register
externally on the scalp,
what is the closest spot to that
region you found in their brain
previously with functional MRI?
And stick the coil right
there, and exactly titrate
its location with reference
to that brain image.
So that makes this whole
enterprise more worthwhile.
So what can TMS tell us
about face perception?
Well, here's the problem.
Here's my fusiform face
area-- that guy right there.
It's a few centimeters in from
the scalp-- from the skull.
So that's a drag.
Unless we opened up my head,
we can't reach it there
with the TMS coil.
Believe me, the first
time I had a chance
to use a TMS coil, the
very first thing I did
was stick the coil there,
crank it to the max,
and try to see
what would happen.
Not a damn thing happened.
It was very disappointing.
I knew lots of friends
who tried the same thing.
It was the most obvious thing.
It just doesn't work;
it's too medial.
Yeah?
Well, there was a question
over here a moment ago?
AUDIENCE: If you use TMS
near someone's brainstem--
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
that wouldn't be so smart.
Luckily, the brainstem
is kind of deep in there.
So if you were really
stupid and stuck it down,
I don't know, way in here, you
might be able to cause trouble.
But mostly, people don't
stick it back there.
And actually, the subjects
won't let you anyway,
because there is a
lot of neck muscles,
and it really hurts when
you do TMS over muscles.
And so if anybody had
such a stupid ideas
to try to zap the
brainstem, the subject
would probably
object immediately
before they got very far with
it, because it would hurt.
[LAUGHS] And you
guys are all probably
wondering, how safe is this?
It's not totally clear.
There have been lots
of studies in animals--
[LAUGHTER]
--where they zap a
rabbit 100,000 times
or something like that
and say, well, rabbit
seems fine, hops around.
And the best they can
do in animal studies.
When I first used TMS
around 20 years ago,
I read a few basic
safety studies,
and I thought,
god, I don't know.
But I also realized that
if you look at the papers,
the initials of the subjects
were the same as the authors.
So I called them up, and I
said, hey, tell me honestly,
did you guys ever notice any
ill effects from getting zapped?
And the guy I talked
to said, yeah, I've
been zapped about 10,000 times,
and I never noticed anything
except for one thing.
After a whole hour
of getting zapped,
it gave me a hell of a
craving for ice cream.
So I decided, OK, I
can live with that.
We got it through the
human subjects committee,
and we do-- not a lot,
but some TMS in my lab.
And I'm probably now been
zapped at least as many times
as that kind, and I guess you
guys can judge for yourself.
So you don't have
the before condition,
so it's a little hard.
Anyway, as far as anybody can
tell, it's perfectly safe.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So there are
some contraindications
if you are prone to
seizures or if you're
on certain medications.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes, yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: So if you ever
sign up for a TMS study,
read the fine print.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Good point, yep.
OK, so back to this.
It would be lovely
to zap that guy,
but it's too hard to reach.
OK, so then, this guy
David Pitcher came along,
and he had a very good idea.
And my 1970s synopsis
of his idea--
paraphrasing still--
is if you can't
zap the region you love,
love the region you can.
And so Pitcher said, hey, what
about that other guy there?
We haven't talked
a lot about it.
It's sometimes called
the occipital face area.
I think of it as a kind of
crappy version of the FFA.
It's kind of face-selective.
It's not as face-selective.
It's more variable, so
it's not as fun to study,
but it's there in most people.
I have a damn fine
one, I have to say--
many people do-- and it is right
out there next to the scalp,
just asking for it.
Right
OK, so here's what
David Pitcher did.
He gave subjects a--
you need a behavioral
task, right?
Because in this case, we're
testing the causal role
of a bit of brain on behavior.
So we're going to
measure behavior.
And so what is our task?
OK, so here's his task.
Sorry, it's a little tiny,
but this is one trial.
Time is going this way.
You present a face.
There's a brief interval.
You present another face.
And the task is just, are those
two faces same or different?
It's your basic face
perception task.
But then, what you can do is
you can zap the occipital face
area at different time--
during presentation
of that second face,
and you can do it at
different time intervals.
Remember, its effect
is very brief.
The actual magnetic change
is less than a millisecond.
OK, so here's what David
Pitcher found in that study.
This is accuracy at the
same different matching
task when you stimulate
the right occipital face
area versus vertex--
that means you stick the coil
up here, which is pretty far
away from face regions.
It's a control condition--
not a perfect one,
but better than nothing.
By the way, TMS usually doesn't
hurt unless you stick it
over muscles.
You stick it over the
frontal lobes, and--
I don't know.
Every time I try to disrupt
my language abilities,
it hurts too much, because
there are muscles up there.
But most places, like the top of
the head, there aren't muscles,
and it doesn't really hurt.
But it still makes a
loud cracking noise,
and it's kind of
like somebody went--
[TAPS SKULL]
--like that.
So you might imagine you need
a control condition, right?
Because if people are--
that also has a
TMS pulse, right?
If you bang somebody
on the head when
they're trying to do
a task, you probably
disrupt their performance.
So you need to bang
them somewhere else
to see if it's specific
to that location.
OK, so OK, so here's a little
effective on the accuracy.
It's not a huge effect size.
So here, it's going from
85% correct to 78% correct
when you zap occipital face
area compared to vertex.
Everybody gets
what's going on here?
So that's good.
That tells us something.
Zapping here messes
up face perception
more than zapping here, OK?
OK, so that tells us
something about causal role,
but what else would
you want to know?
That's a beginning,
but having just learned
what I told you
about TMS, what else
could you do that
would tell you more?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You see
the face [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Ah, well,
that's a good question.
It wasn't what I
was fishing for,
but it's a very good point.
So this shows disruption, but
I showed you with that video
before that if you
electrically stimulate the FFA,
you see a face.
Well, unfortunately,
nobody has reported
that when you zap a face area,
you see a percept of a face.
Boy, that would be fun if
true, but it doesn't work.
And there's much
debate about why.
It probably has to
do with the fact
that your ability to
target just that region
is less good than it is
with direct stimulation.
There are many reports
and many published studies
where if you zap V1, you
see a flash of light, OK?
I don't see the
damn flash of light.
I've tried, and
tried, and tried,
and people in my lab
who I trust promised me
they actually see it.
It isn't just BS.
But I don't know;
I don't see it.
Anyway, so probably,
the question
of when you get disruption and
when you get a positive percept
is a very interesting,
complicated one.
I think it will
ultimately have to do
with how those batches
of neurons not only
respond to faces, or
light, or whatever,
but how they code
for that information,
such that when you put a big
artifactual, non-biological
signal in there, will
it have any meaning
that the subject can interpret?
I don't know if that's helpful.
I think nobody really
understands that, when
you get a positive percept.
But I hope you can
at least understand
that at least if you mess
with it and muck it up,
you can disrupt.
That logic is clear.
When you will be able to
actually stick in a signal
and get a positive,
coherent percept
is a more subtle thing, OK?
OK, what else would
you want to know?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Whether it messes
up object perception, or not?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Absolutely, absolutely.
All we're showing here is it's
messing up face perception.
Maybe the guy can't see here.
Maybe he's just globally blind.
Maybe he'd have the same
problem with object perception,
absolutely.
The assigned reading
for Wednesday
shows exactly that
experiment, OK?
What else would
you want to know?
Remember, a TMS pulse lasts
less than a millisecond.
That enables us to ask a whole
interesting kind of question.
What else could we find out?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh, just [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, yeah.
I'm sorry.
It's probably-- I don't mean to
be insulting your intelligence.
You're probably sitting there
saying, this is too obvious.
That's what I'm talking about.
You can zap at
different times and ask,
when is the information
going through there?
When is that region playing
a causal role in behavior?
And here is a very beautiful
data that David got.
And there's basically
no effect at any point
other than that interval between
60 and 100 milliseconds, OK?
So that's cool.
Tells you that's when
that region is likely
engaged in processing.
Make sense?
OK, and is it Shardul?
Yes, already made the point.
I was going to ask
you guys, does this
tell us this region
is specifically
involved in face perception?
Absolutely not.
We'd have to test other things.
It could affect
every visual percept.
OK, so you can read
more about that.
All right, just so to
collect all the advantages,
it gives you strong
causal evidence
that a particular
part of the brain
is involved in
perception or behavior.
It has good temporal
information,
unlike studying patients
with focal brain damage.
And it is the only
disruption method
that can be used in
normal humans, OK?
So that's why, even though
it's so crude and rudimentary,
we use it, because it's the only
thing that fills that niche.
A couple other
unimportant things.
Spatial resolution isn't
as good as we'd like,
but it's surprising how much
you can learn nonetheless.
And it doesn't reach
very far below the scalp,
although Ed Boyden--
the amazing Ed Boyden--
is working on a crazy new
version of it that might.
OK, so where have all this
menagerie of methods gotten us
to?
I won't go through
all this in detail.
We listed all these
questions before.
I gave you some of the
answers from previous methods.
The ones we've just talked
about show, for example,
that the fusiform face area--
or the occipital face area.
In the case of TMS--
are causally involved in
face perception, apparently
not in object
perception, pending
the paper you're going to read.
And so that's
important, because it
says when we try to
come up with theories
of how face
recognition works, we
might think about having a
different theory for face
recognition from our theory
of object recognition.
OK, so this is all
magnificent and wonderful,
but I finessed this list of
questions so that the methods
would be able to address
them-- at least a little bit--
and I sneakily left off a
whole suite of other questions
that are extremely
important-- arguably more
important-- that those
methods don't address, OK?
So we want to know not just
that a region responds to faces.
We want to know exactly
what is represented
in that region or other regions
that respond to other things.
We want to know, what is
the neural code for faces?
We want to know, what are the
actual computations that go on
in a given region, how
do they unfold over time,
and how do those
computations produce
the representations and
behavioral abilities
that we measure?
We want to know, what are the
actual anatomical connections?
I showed you that
little occipital
face area right nearby but
discontiguous from the fusiform
face area.
I've wanted to know for 20 years
whether those damn things are
connected anatomically.
Shockingly, we still
don't know that.
We want to know what
is the causal role
of each region in perception.
And I showed you a few ways that
we get little bits of data--
kind of, sort of-- but there's
a lot of cases where we don't.
And we want to know, how does
all this stuff get wired up
over development, right?
What is the role of experience?
Do you need to see faces to
wire up the phase region,
or is it there at birth
before you ever see a face?
The sad truth is,
for the most part,
we don't have good
methods to answer
these questions in humans.
So that's just a big
bummer, but it's true.
Most of these
questions can only be
answered by research in
animals, or can be best answered
by research in animals.
So I'm going to take
a moment to talk
about ethical issues
in animal research,
just to note that I
think there is an issue.
And I'll say that
it's not unreasonable
if you have qualms.
I noticed in an
earlier lecture, I
started talking about
recording from animal brains,
and I didn't have time at
that moment to mark this,
but I do think it's important.
If it makes you uneasy,
that's totally legitimate.
You should think about
that, and respect that,
and think hard about
whether that's--
what you make of that.
Unambiguously, causing
animals pointless suffering
is just completely
unacceptable, OK?
So I think we can
all agree on that.
And I think there's a
very difficult trade-off
between avoiding suffering
in animals and research
that has saved countless lives.
So people can
legitimately come down
on different sides of this, but
many lives have been saved--
including mine-- based
on animal research
that enabled treatments
that were life-saving.
And a few things to
think about to help you
inform how you handle
that trade-off.
First of all, know that animal
research in the United States
is very heavily regulated, OK?
So animals receive
excellent vet care--
shockingly, better
than probably lots
of citizens of this country.
That's another topic.
Also, there's a very major
emphasis on avoiding pain.
So I think it's
probably generally true
that it's infrequent that lab
animals suffer a lot of pain.
Researchers and vets are
very careful to avoid that.
So the bigger issue
is not so much
are the animals physically
suffering from pain, per se,
but what kind of life
is it to live in a lab
and be a lab animal?
And I think that's a
legitimate question.
For monkeys, at least, where
I, at least-- and maybe
in my speciesist bias, being
more sympathetic to similar
species.
I don't know if that's
legitimate, but it's a natural.
There are increasing efforts
to improve the quality of life
for monkeys in labs.
Many monkeys are now
housed in social groups
where they can hang out
with their families,
and that certainly improves
their quality of life.
Many monkeys basically
play video games all day.
In DiCarlo Lab, they're
studying visual perception,
and what do they do?
They get the monkeys in there
basically doing visual tasks
in exchange for juice rewards.
Not all that
different from what,
probably, lots of you guys do.
Now, maybe they'd be
happier in nature.
Probably, much of the time,
they'd be happier in nature.
But I think that's
complicated, too.
Nature can be pretty nasty.
So it's not totally obvious that
quality of life in a random lab
is worse than quality
of life in nature.
The third point, I'd say, is
that the benefits of research
are forever.
You discover something
major about how brains work,
that's forever, right?
So you've got to
amortize whatever
cost of animal suffering there
is against the forever-ness
of that insight.
And so in my view--
not that you need to agree--
but in my view, animal research
is vastly more justifiable
than things like
eating meat or buying
leather, which is just transient
entertainment or convenience,
right?
So anyway, you guys,
I encourage you all
to think hard about this and to
come to different conclusions.
I just wanted to note that
these are issues that are worth
thinking about.
That said, the methods in animal
research are breathtaking,
and they get more and more
breathtaking every day.
In this building,
people are constantly
inventing astonishing
new ways to answer
all kinds of questions.
And I wanted to give
you just a gist of some
of the kind of
stuff that you can
do to answer that
list of questions
that I said we can't
really answer in humans.
So just very briefly--
this used to be a whole
lecture, but I've decided
to cut it to one slide--
very briefly, about
10-plus years ago,
these two amazing people, Doris
Tsao and Winrich Freiwald--
who, mark my words, will
get a Nobel Prize someday,
or at least they
should, and they might--
they popped a monkey
in the scanner
and did the very same experiment
that we do on humans, OK?
So here's a monkey brain.
Again, the cortex is unfolded so
you can see the whole surface.
The dark bits are the bits
that used to be inside a fold.
The little yellow
patches are the patches
that respond more to
faces than objects--
just analogous to
the FFA in humans,
but there are six little
patches in monkeys.
OK, so that's so far,
that's like, OK, fine,
monkeys have them, too.
That's cool.
But the thing is,
because that's a monkey,
you can then stick electrodes
straight into that region
right there, and you
can record from hundreds
of neurons in that region.
And you can record
the response of each
of those hundreds of neurons
to hundreds or thousands
of stimuli.
You can characterize
the neural code
for faces in monkeys in a way
that you just can't for humans.
In fact, Doris now
published a paper last year
called "The Neural
Code for Faces,"
based on a decade
of this research.
It's quite breathtaking.
OK, second, you can watch
those representations change,
those neural population
codes change over time.
You can see, at one time
point, what the code seems
to be saying here, and
then here, and then here,
and you can watch that--
those codes-- change over
time in each of those regions.
And you can see
different representations
in each of those regions.
It's quite breathtaking.
You can answer this
question of, what
are the anatomical connections
between these regions,
with a whole bunch
of different methods
that I won't go through here.
But you can actually answer
what's connected to what.
And what these
guys have found is
that all of those
yellow face patches
are connected to each other
by long-range connections that
go through the white matter
underneath the gray matter.
Those regions are
not connected at all
to the intervening
other patches of cortex.
So that set of
six little regions
is like a computational
unit with different hubs
that talk to each other.
And you can see all
that in monkeys in a way
that we still don't
know in humans.
You can electrically stimulate,
or disrupt with other methods,
any one of those
patches one at a time.
You can disrupt them
for 50 milliseconds
here, 200 milliseconds
there, whatever you like.
And you can study this whole
system over development.
How does it change from
shortly after birth
to monkey adolescence?
And you can control
experience during development.
You can raise
monkeys without ever
letting them see faces, and
ask whether seeing a face
is necessary for the
development of that region.
We'll talk about that
in a few lectures.
My point is just that
with animal research
you can answer vastly
richer, more sophisticated
questions than you could
ever answer in humans,
and that's just life.
Yes, what's your name?
AUDIENCE: I'm Esther.
NANCY KANWISHER: Esther, hi.
AUDIENCE: So in
these experiments,
they showed them
monkey faces, right?
Not humans?
NANCY KANWISHER: Done
all different ways.
Remember, monkeys
see other monkeys,
but they see a lot
of humans, too.
And monkey face patches respond
pretty similarly to human
faces and monkey faces.
Human faces respond pretty
similarly to human faces
and monkey faces, too--
even if you don't
work in a monkey lab.
OK, so just to say that there
are loads of other methods,
and we'll get these
later in the course.
OK, so that snake assignment,
I hope that seemed--
I thought you guys, for the
most part, did very well
and did exactly the kind of
things that we had in mind.
And I just want to go through
a few bits of terminology,
because I realized, some of
you who messed up the wording,
I hadn't really fully explained
what the different words mean.
OK, so first of all, there's
this incredibly boring words
of independent variables
and dependent variables.
And frankly, I
didn't know which was
which until I started teaching
this stuff a few years ago.
But the concept is
really important.
An independent variable,
that's a factor that you,
the experimentalist,
manipulate and change,
so that you can then
measure what effect it
has on a brain or behavior.
The effect you measure is
the dependent variable.
The independent variable is
called the independent variable
because you, the
experimentalist,
get to mess with it, get
to manipulate it, OK?
The dependent one, you're
measuring its dependence
on the independent one.
So just basically,
in the experiment,
you muck with
something in the world,
and you measure
the consequences.
The thing you muck with is
the independent variable.
The muckee, the thing you
measure the effect on,
is the dependent variable.
Make sense?
OK.
All right, so for example,
the bold response,
that's a dependent variable, and
pretty much all the experiments
we'll talk about here.
All right, the hypothesis,
most of you got that.
The hypothesis is the
statement about the world
that you're trying
to figure out if it's
true in your experiment, OK?
A prediction-- most of you
got this, but let me just say,
a prediction is supposed
to be extremely precise.
It's the exact
statement of what you
will see when you measure
your dependent variable
if the hypothesis is true.
What is the crucial
thing you have
to look for in the data
you measure that tells you
if the hypothesis
is true or not?
And the prediction
is what you will find
if the hypothesis is true, OK?
Confound-- we haven't
talked about this yet.
A confound is a difference
between your conditions
that you're manipulating
other than the one you
intend to manipulate.
And hence, confounds give
you alternative accounts.
Case in point, we
compare the response
in the brain when people look
at faces versus when they look
at a bunch of random objects.
The fact that the faces
have more curvy surfaces,
or are animate, or
are more interesting,
those are all confounds with
respect to the hypothesis
that that region is responding
specifically to faces.
Everybody got that?
OK, it's very common,
amid undergraduates,
to use confound to mean anything
bad about an experiment.
That's not right.
A confound is a very
particular thing.
It's another dimension that
co-varies with the thing
that you care about.
It's like a nuisance
variable that's
correlated with the thing
you're manipulating,
and hence is giving you
a difficulty inferring
a clean inference
from your data.
All right, a contrast.
We talked about
activations in the brain,
like those little yellow patches
I showed in monkey brains
a moment ago.
That shows you the bits
that responded more
in functional MRI
when that monkey was
looking at faces than objects.
The contrast is faces
versus objects, right?
It's looking for
a higher response
in one condition than another.
Make sense?
OK, these should
all be fairly clear.
I just know that not
everybody got this.
OK, now, the point of a contrast
is to isolate a mental process,
OK?
So let's talk about
that for a second.
So how do we decide
what contrasts to use?
OK, well, first
thing you have to do
is get clear about
your hypothesis.
State it explicitly.
Most of you guys did
that really well.
Often, your hypothesis-- with
functional MRI, at least--
will concern a particular mental
process that you're studying--
like face recognition.
Now, remember,
importantly-- I said
this briefly way
back-- functional
MRI can only tell
you about differences
between two conditions.
The absolute number, you're
going to measure the MR signal
intensity in one
condition-- say,
when people are
looking at faces--
and it's going to be
something like 726.
And it's totally meaningless.
That's just how strong the
MRI signal is from that point.
It doesn't mean a
damn thing on its own.
But then, if we also measure,
in that same part of the brain,
the MR signal intensity when the
subject is looking at objects,
and it's 720, then now
we're in business, OK?
All right, so everything
is a difference.
So that means that in
any imaging experiment,
you'll need to compare
two or more conditions.
One condition will
never get you anything.
And if you want to isolate
a particular mental process,
you need to turn that
mental process on or off,
or you need to vary how
strongly it's turned on.
So this is all in
the service of,
how are we going to decide
what contrast to use?
That's our goal, is to turn
on or off one little thing.
OK, and here's the problem.
If I told you, OK,
look at my face,
and don't process low-level
visual information,
and don't think about
what I'm saying.
Just see my face.
It's like, what?
You can't do that, right?
There's a whole
processing chain.
You can't just do one little
mental process at a time.
And so that means
we can't just have
a task where you do
only mental process x,
and a task where you
don't do mental process x,
If you're not doing other stuff.
So what that means is we need to
choose two tasks, each of which
has lots of mental processes,
but that differ in only one.
And then, we can
compare those two.
So this is called
subtraction logic,
and it comes from
work over 100 years
ago in cognitive
psychology and people
who were just
measuring behavior.
This dude, Donders, he's
a Dutch physiologist,
and he invented the subtraction
method to measure reaction
times in humans, way back.
And so with functional MRI,
we're doing the same thing.
So we're going to come up
with two different tasks which
involve the whole suite, from
input, to mental processing,
to output.
And yet, we're going to try
to make them differ in just
one particular mental process.
Everybody with the program here?
OK, all right, so what you
aspire toward in the contrasts
that you choose is something
called a minimal pair, right?
So the idea is we're going
to have these two tasks that
are identical in every respect,
except for that one thing
we care about, OK?
So here's a task,
and here's a task.
This one involves
snake perception,
and this one is
identical to this one,
except for snake perception.
That's what we want.
OK, and if you get
those two things, that's
called a minimal pair.
And this is the single
most important thing
in experimental design.
All the other stuff--
like how you arrange
your stimuli over time
and all that kind of stuff--
OK, it matters a little bit, but
this is the crux of the matter.
What are those
conditions, and are they
the right kind of minimal pair?
And you guys got the gist,
but I felt like most of you
didn't really engage.
OK, what exactly were
those non-snake conditions?
So that's really the
crux of the matter.
So the most common problem
with imaging experiments
is not that the scanner wasn't
as fancy as it could have been,
or they didn't use the latest
cutting-edge analysis method.
The most common problem is
that people's contrasts--
their conditions--
were not designed
beautifully enough to isolate
a single mental process, OK?
That is that the conditions
were not minimal pairs.
Any other difference
between the two conditions
other than the one you
intend is a confound.
All right, so let's
engage on this.
Now, if we ran a
whole experiment only
on male subjects,
is that a confound?
No.
Why not, Isabelle?
AUDIENCE: Because it's not
a difference between the two
experimental conditions.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, it's
just a bad design feature,
or something that limits your
ability to draw inferences.
Again, sub-optimal design it's
not the same as a confound.
A confound is this
very particular thing.
OK, if all the snake pictures
have grassy backgrounds,
and all the non-snake conditions
do not, is that a confound?
Yeah, exactly a confound, right.
OK, so I just said all this,
so I'll stop boring you.
OK, and the reason that
the grassy background
thing is a confound is it gives
you an alternative account
of that contrast.
Maybe it's grassiness,
not snake-ness,
that's the key difference.
You don't know.
OK, all right.
OK, so all of that
said, minimum pairs
are like a platonic ideal
of experimental design.
What you aspire toward, but
you can never really do it.
If the two conditions were
identical except for this one
little thing,
they'd be identical.
You can never
totally pull it off,
but you can track the little
ways in which you fail,
and you can test them one at a
time in later experiments, OK?
All right, good.
All right, so here's
what we're going to do.
We're going to
break into groups,
and you guys are going to think
how to take the kind of designs
that you already put
together and turn them
into actual experiments-- which
is going to require deciding
on a whole bunch
of other things,
and then we're going to discuss
the things you come up with.
OK, what are the
exact conditions
you'll run in your experiment?
So we could spend a whole
class talking about this.
So I'd love to
hear your best-ofs,
but I don't want to engage
on that for a whole class.
A lot of the keys,
some of you guys
had very clever
non-snake conditions
to test to get close
to minimal pairs.
I want to hear about those.
But then, beyond
that, here's something
that probably none
of you mentioned.
It's understandable; I don't
think I said much about it.
What are subjects
doing in the scanner?
Are they just lying there,
and the stimuli are just
flashing up, and they're
going dumdy-dumdy-dum?
Are they doing something
with the stimuli?
Go think about what you would
want to have happen, OK?
So what is the task?
Third, some of you mentioned
baseline conditions
but didn't really
say what they are.
What would a baseline
condition be?
And do you want them, or
is it a waste of scan time?
Think about that.
OK, next, suppose
you get to scan
10 subjects for one hour each.
Now, think about how that
design is actually going to go.
Are you going to assign
different conditions
to different subjects--
so these five people will
see all the snake images,
and these five people will
see all the non-snake images?
Or, are you going to have
snakes and non-snakes
within each subject?
Next, it's nice to not make
the subject do their task
non-stop for an hour.
We usually give subjects breaks.
So we break an experiment into
pieces of 3 to 10 minutes--
or whatever I wrote, yeah.
And so those are called runs.
So think about how
you want to allocate
those conditions to runs.
And how many runs
will you include?
And then, think
about what's going
to happen within each run.
So if you're going to
have multiple conditions
within a run, are you going
to stick all of the snake
conditions in the first half
and all the non-snake conditions
in the second half?
If not, why not?
And if there are multiple
conditions within a run,
yeah, are you going to
clump them all together
or interleave them randomly, and
what are the trade-offs there?
And, what is the order of
conditions within a run?
And we won't get to
number 10 for the moment.
OK, so we're going to break
you guys into four groups,
and you're going to
talk amongst yourselves
and try to come up
with your best answers
to these in five, 10,
minutes, something like that.
And then, we're going
to pull your thoughts
on this when we get back, OK?
OK, so part of my
agenda in doing this
is just to break up the
monotony of me going blah,
blah, blah, because experimental
design is like, it's important,
but it's not the
most riveting thing.
The other thing is,
experimental design is basically
just organized common sense.
And so most of this
stuff, you guys
just answered all
these questions just
by thinking about them.
You need to know a few
things about the methods,
but really, in experimental
design, the biggest, the best
guideline, the best way to think
about design is think about,
OK you're the subject.
You're lying in the scanner.
You're doing that.
Does that work?
Are you actually
going to be doing what
you're supposed to be doing?
Are you going to be selectively
turning on and off this one
little mental process
you care about,
or are you doing a
million other things,
like falling asleep, and
getting bored, and all of that,
and predicting what's
going to happen next,
and all that kind of stuff?
OK, all right, so let's
just take a few examples.
What were some good kinds
of control conditions-- that
is, non-snake stimuli that are
good to compare to snakes that
maybe aren't perfect
minimal pairs,
but that get partway there?
I saw a few, just in the
few papers that I looked at.
Yeah, I've got a--
I'm sorry, I've asked
your name like six times.
But I'm going to--
on my trusty sheet, tell
me again how you say it?
AUDIENCE: Achay.
NANCY KANWISHER: Achay.
OK.
AUDIENCE: So for ours, we
compared snakes to worms.
NANCY KANWISHER: To worms, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because they
have really similar shapes.
NANCY KANWISHER: Awesome,
and they're both animate.
That's great, love it.
What else?
Who else had a good
control condition?
Or who had an interest
in control condition?
Yes, sorry, your name is--
AUDIENCE: Lauren.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes, OK.
AUDIENCE: Yep, our group had
pretty much the same baseline
background, and we
would just superimpose
images of different objects on
it so that remained consistent
throughout.
NANCY KANWISHER: Uh-huh, and
the background was like what?
AUDIENCE: Forest floor.
NANCY KANWISHER: Uh-huh, OK.
So you stick a toaster
on the forest floor
or something like that, versus
a snake or something, yeah?
AUDIENCE: The idea was
more like other animals,
or stuff that would
make more sense.
NANCY KANWISHER: That's good.
That deals with the grass
confound problem, right?
Absolutely, very good.
What else?
David, you had
interesting ideas.
AUDIENCE: Well, we
were talking a lot
about animate versus
inanimate things,
so like comparing
to a garden hose.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yes, garden hose!
Love it!
I actually ran this experiment
a bunch of years ago,
and we used a garden hose--
or a bunch of garden hoses,
coiled up in the grass.
We tried to make them
slither and all that.
Anyway, but garden
hose is great.
Say more.
You had other good
ideas in your--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we also-- we
talked about some of my ideas
were looking at
videos, with motion.
NANCY KANWISHER: Why?
AUDIENCE: What'd you say?
AUDIENCE: Oh, because
when you get a snake,
it kind of slithers and has
this very distinctive thing,
that it feels like the
motion is what creeps me
out when I see a snake.
NANCY KANWISHER: Totally.
Me, too.
AUDIENCE: And if you
have a rigid thing that
looked like a snake, but it
was just sliding rigidly,
then it wouldn't
really creep me out.
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
This is a key insight, right?
So think about if we're
interested in how you perceive
snakes, we want to know not just
how you do it in some weird lab
environment.
We want to know how
you'd actually do that.
The whole reason
to choose snakes
is it seems like something that
could be biologically relevant.
There might be special hardware.
When I'm out hiking and I
see even a curved stick,
I, like, jump and shriek
before I can censor myself.
It's horrible.
I find it very embarrassing.
It's not consistent
with my self-image.
But I have no control
over it; it just happens.
And so I've thought
for a long time,
there's some damn bit of my
brain that's making me do that,
and it pisses me off,
and I'm going to find it.
Well, we looked
and didn't find it.
But anyway, you go
from those intuitions.
Often, your own introspections
are very informative,
and I think your intuition
is exactly right.
There's a very characteristic
motion that snakes have,
and it could be
that that's the cue.
So then, the trick is you have
slithery motion versus what?
I don't know.
That's hard.
What other kinds of
motions could you have?
AUDIENCE: Right, so you could
have just even rigid motion,
where it's not slithering,
or it's not changing shape.
It's just sliding or rotating.
NANCY KANWISHER: Right.
Right, exactly.
Anyway, all those
are all good ideas.
Good, so what should the
subject do in the scanner?
Should they lie there
and go dumdy-dumdy-dum?
Should they do a task?
If so, what task?
Oh, if you guys
don't volunteer, I'm
going to start
calling on people--
even though, as
the Jenkins study,
showed it's nearly impossible to
look at these damn photographs
and figure out who's who.
David, in the back.
AUDIENCE: So--
NANCY KANWISHER: Task.
Task, or no task?
What task?
AUDIENCE: Yes, we talked about
having the subjects find a way
to indicate that they're paying
attention and not just dozing
off.
NANCY KANWISHER: Right.
AUDIENCE: So one idea was to
have them essentially indicate
the source, make [INAUDIBLE]
think about a bunch of problems
like, well, we don't want
them thinking about snakes
for the entire our experiment.
So--
NANCY KANWISHER: Also, if
they're going to tell you
they're seeing a snake,
maybe by pushing a button,
then on the snake trails,
they're pushing a button,
and on the non-snake
trials, they're not.
AUDIENCE: Well, on
the non-snake trials,
they would push another button.
NANCY KANWISHER: Ah, but then
they have two different motor
responses.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so then we would
have them run the experiment
again, but switch buttons.
NANCY KANWISHER: Good, good.
Smart, very nice.
AUDIENCE: Ideally,
we might just have
them perform a task that's
completely unrelated to looking
at snakes or thinking
about snakes,
just so that they're
not affecting--
NANCY KANWISHER:
Absolutely, and the point
you made before is a good one.
If you're looking for
snakes all the time, maybe
even if it's apples and dogs,
you're thinking, is it a snake?
Is it a snake?
And maybe you're using that
region, and it's a mess, right?
Absolutely, yeah.
All right, so this
is a common challenge
in experimental design,
and these things
don't have clear right answers.
What I want you to do is
just see the trade-offs.
On the one hand, just
passive viewing, lying there,
is good in a way.
The things are just
impinging on your sensoria,
and it's doing
whatever it will do.
But the downside is subjects
fall asleep and get bored,
and you don't know
if they're awake.
So that's a problem.
OK, but the key thing
is whatever the task is,
you don't want the task
to engage asymmetrically
with the stimulus condition,
because then you're
building in a confound, right?
So in the group I was in, we
were talking about, well, you
could have people--
well, we were talking, actually,
about faces and objects
in that case.
So you could have
people name the things,
but if they're naming
snakes versus non-snakes,
it's not very good if
they're going snake,
snake, snake, snake,
snake, dog, toaster, apple.
One is easier than the
other and more repetitive.
There are all kinds
of problems there.
All right, baseline conditions.
I didn't really say what
a baseline condition was.
Sorry about that.
What I meant by a baseline
is different from a control
condition.
The control condition
would be like non-snakes
contrasted with the snakes.
Baseline tends to be like a
minimalist condition that's
supposed to turn the brain off.
Can we turn the brain off?
No, of course not, but
we can aspire toward it.
We can go partway out there.
We can say, OK, if
we're studying vision,
let's minimize activity in the
visual system as best we can,
OK?
So you could just
have a blank screen
that feels like a
pretty minimal thing.
You can have people
close their eyes.
The reason that, in
vision experiments,
people tend to have fixation,
where there's a tiny dot
and subjects are supposed
to hold their eyes on it,
is that in natural- left
of their own devices,
people move their eyes a
lot-- several times a second.
And moving your eyes produces
all kinds of activity and lots
of neurons.
And so it's a very
active visual thing,
even if there's
nothing on the screen.
And so staring at dot is
closer to shutting off
your visual system, even though
it's not shutting it off.
OK, so given that most of the
contrasts we've talked about
are like faces versus
objects or snakes
versus non-snakes, and all the
activations that I've shown you
guys are contrast between
an experimental condition
and a control condition, why
are we bothering with baseline?
It doesn't even figure
in that contrast.
Yes, Jimmy?
AUDIENCE: Well, if
the region is truly
selective for only snakes,
you could use the baseline as,
in this sense, like a control,
because you can compare
the other control to it.
If it's really
selective for snakes,
then the non-snake object should
respond in the same as the
[? minimal. ?]
NANCY KANWISHER: Awesome,
everybody get that?
So that was exactly right.
And this is, I think, a
very interesting point.
So suppose we have--
remember, with MRI, you
just have two numbers.
So here's the snake
response, and here's
the non-snake response.
If we don't have a baseline,
that's all we have--
two numbers, OK?
And that's fine.
If we run enough subjects,
that could be significant.
But now, let's think what else
we know if we have a baseline.
Suppose we have a baseline
of staring at dot.
And that's down here.
We'll call that fixation.
Are you impressed?
And you've run enough
subjects, so that's
significantly different.
Are you impressed?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Less so than if
the fixation were higher up.
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly!
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because then, if
the results are higher up--
or if the fixation is the
second one that you just drew--
then the response to a snake
is twice as much as non-snake.
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
Does everybody see how-- yeah,
that might be significant,
but who cares, right?
Some tiny little
ratty-ass effect,
versus if it's like
here, or even--
this is the case Jimmy was
talking about, like that.
No response at all
more than staring at a
dot to the non-snakes, and yet
this response to the snakes.
That would even more impressive.
So there are different
degrees of selectivity, right?
Not just does it
respond differentially,
but how selective is it?
Oh, boy, I'm going
way over time.
I'm sorry.
So you guys did great
thinking through these things.
And, of course, I didn't get
halfway through my lecture.
That's OK, we'll roll over
the best parts for later,
and the ones that
aren't that fun
will just go by the wayside.
I will put notes on the rest
of some of these things,
but I think all of
you guys pulled out--
just thinking hard about
it and using common sense,
you can see that a lot
of experimental design
is common sense.
All right, see you
guys on Wednesday.